you
[Music]
okay good morning everyone
we're going to get started thank you
everyone for coming this morning
we're excited to have I think this is
our fourth quantum quantum workshop as
part of the faculty summit so thanks for
coming we have a pretty full schedule
and we have a pretty diverse set of
topics so it should be a pretty fun day
we're going to start this morning and
hear from Andrew Gillian he's going to
talk about optimizing quantum
optimization algorithms so let's welcome
Adarsh Thank You Krista is the mic
working fine yes this is joint work with
Nathan vibha and Srinivasan I'm gonna
charm I mean now intern at Microsoft
Research for the summer and I'm working
on this with Nathan which we started in
January together so I would like to give
a quick overview of my talk first
ingredient in my talk is an improved
gradient calculation algorithm which is
based on Jordans algorithm from 2005 and
in other ingredients to make this
fitting the machine learning
applications I want to show is to
calculate the gradient of success
probability and I show how it fits many
machine learning applications or or
quantum all two encoders quantum
optimization algorithms and so on and on
the quantum of to include aside there
was an interesting paper end of last
year see the I want to show this
application particular to this problem
so the basic idea of the gradient
calculation item is fairly simple it's
based on the quantum Fourier transform I
want to show this slide on Fourier
transform because it's a slightly
unusual normalization of the Fourier
transform I just want to make sure that
it's it's the same usual Fourier
transform so instead of dealing with
large numbers between 0 & 2 to the N
I want to deal with basically precise
precise real numbers so I just rescale
all my numbers to be between zero and
one and if I work with X and K now I n
cubed states which are on this grid in 0
& 1 and due to this normalization when I
do the Fourier transform then I don't
divide by an x on just a normal goes to
this way anyway the free transform from
such a state would give me back the
basically the momentum of the state the
K vector and ya Fourier transform is a
very useful in many quantum algorithms
it's easy to implement with a few gates
and it is the basic basis of many
exponential speed ups in quantum
algorithms and it's relatively
insensitive to small distributions in
the face it's kind of robust a method
and here is now the idea how do you
apply to actual gradient calculation
problem so now we assume that we have a
function which we which is like a B
dimensional function f and it is given
us in a phase Oracle so that for value
which is now a point in a d-dimensional
space it will produce a phase which is
proportional to the function value
itself so this is the input model with
which we work and I'll show what is the
basic idea of the gradient calculation
algorithm so the algorithm starts with
preparing uniform superposition over now
all the points on this b dimensional
grid which is just 0 1 to the D so this
any course superposition is easy
earth then I apply my phaser record and
I applied enzymes so that I guess an end
time is the function value interface and
now I say that suppose that this
function is close to linear around zero
then a basic the approximate the
function value as the function value at
zero plus the gradient times the
distance to zero so it basically
translates to a global phase which is
the function value at zero and then this
part which is the linear part linear
function approximation and this is the
same form what what was an Agins
basically what was a natural what was
the image opposite of a single like
momentum vector that is the same thing
that it appears here so if I now apply
quantum Fourier transform which is not d
dimensional which is just meaning that I
do a fully a transform in each dimension
then I actually hopefully get back the
gradient vector itself as a bit string
representation so I can actually read
out this value classically so the basic
challenge here is to approximate the
area and make sure that the linear
approximation that I used that's
actually good enough so for this I
assume that my function is a analytic
and then one thing that I could do I
could do I could use is just rescaling
the function I can multiply the function
itself with some large number number art
and also divide the variables by r then
in the Taylor series each term gets a
basically divided by a large power of
art except the constant term and the
gradient itself which remains constant
so this is a nice trick but the problem
is since I only have Oracle access to
the function itself whenever I rescale
the function basically one-one Oracle
query to the new function is R times the
number of queries to the original
function so it's expensive to do this
rescaling nevertheless basically this
was the way like Jordan dies with the
error and this was suboptimal so this is
where we applied some tricks from
numerical analysis and yeah the basic
idea was to use a higher degree or
higher order numerical differential
formulas which is basically based on an
interpolation polynomial I can do higher
and higher order approximations for my
function by evaluating it a few more
points so this is for example very nice
approximation it's easy to see that the
second order term is canceled from the
Taylor series if I use this formula and
the gradient is preserved so this if I
use this thing which basically means
that first query F for X then like do
inverse query which is just the unitary
inverse of the query function for minus
X so this is already a much better
approximation to my function which
completely surfaces the second order
term and yeah so one can push this idea
further but it's a long longer
calculation involving some higher order
calculus but the basic theorem the few
could prove along these lines that if I
have the dimensional analytic function
and all partial derivatives are at most
one then I can find a finite difference
formula of order logarithmic order which
satisfies that the function and the
actual function of sorry it's a typo it
should be the gradient times X so that
this function is almost the gradient
times X almost completely in linear so
it should be gradient 1/2 0 X and so
like this function is a epsilon close to
being linear over the this B dimensional
hyper tube but so there are two
subtleties here one that it's the
somatic symmetrized
hypercube so I need to Center the zero
in the middle then it works much better
turns out the other thing that actually
it doesn't quite work on the like unit
hypercube but I need to rescale the
hypercube a little bit so it's only in a
smaller fraction but still a relatively
nice fraction of the hypercube can be
linearized linearized by this trick
yeah so this was the analytic result
that we needed to prove and the actual
physical complexity after some more work
that the best theorem which which we
could basically prove using this result
the following so if I have a function
which was again analytic and why we
could slightly lift the requirement so
now the requirement is that if I
calculate partial derivative like which
which involves key derivation then the
absolute value of this of this number
should be always less than some constant
C to the K times square root K factorial
this is just what we could prove and
under these circumstances the query
complexity turns out to be
if x squared with the over epsilon and
this query result is like quadratic
improvement in epsilon compared to
Jordan's result and it's also this
square with the scaling was non regular
Center what also was only considering
like up to second or third order terms
the Taylor series so our proof is
actually much more years and yeah and it
uses this higher dimensional tricks and
we could also prove matching lower bound
so our lower bound to show that actually
for this class of functions satisfying
this requirement on the gradient on the
partial derivatives you actually cannot
cannot solve this problem with less
queries if you have a phase or a cola
and well the lower bound technique is
based on the hybrid method which was
used for the original grower lower bound
but it's it's not the grow it you cannot
reduce it to the global load bound you
need to reduce it to the proof of the
prove a lower bound and it's very
involved so I just wanted to quickly
[Music]
study a heuristic argument by this
Fourier transform needs is many queries
so now this is the argument suppose that
F is analytic and F is upper bounded by
one in absolute value its gradient is
close to uniform one so it's kind of
large the gradient and well if you want
the Fourier transform to actually get me
back this gradient vector then my state
before the Fourier transform
something close to this expression well
this is the important part in the faces
and so the question is what is the
typical magnitude of these phases
because each phase I can get by face
query each face query as at most one to
my face
of course faces wraparound but still I
need to somehow
this wrapped around large faces so the
heuristic argument is that that this
expression is a basically the typical
value is n times square would be so
radiant s is almost all the ones so this
is just the sum of the coordinates of X
and by the central limit theorem the
typical value of the absolute value of
the sum of this coordinate is just
square would be + n that was my
basically that was a 1 over the
precision so the number of digits I can
read out so this translates to Epsilon
so I need square would be over epsilon
queries this is of course not the proof
it just shows you why this might be the
right scaling and we have a rigorous
proof as well ok so this was about the
gradient calculation now how can we
apply so first concentrate on the lower
part part of this circle which is now a
model of kind of most quantum
optimization algorithms so the idea is
that you have some starting state which
is just usually the all 0 state you have
some circuit which has some parameters
you can you have some gates which you
can tune and you hope that this circuit
does something that you want there's a
verifying circuit at the end which kind
of tests whether this quantum state that
you prepared is a good quantum state for
your purposes and outputs 1 if it's if
it's a good quantum state so this is
kind of a benchmark and this is the the
algorithm that you want to fine-tune it
could be like like in machine learning
it could be a classification circuit or
it could be a quantum optimization
algorithm quantum approximate
optimization algorithm of quantum
variation against over so it could be it
could be many things and
so these are the tuning parameters which
Nyad did so these parameters can be
classical and then this is just a
circuit but now I want to use our
algorithm to actually to actually
somehow interact with this circuit and
in a our algorithm we needed to to input
these values classically so the idea
here is that the objective function
which I want to maximize is the
probability of measuring one here on the
outcome and this probability depends on
the only parameters of the circuit which
my input in a quantum way if these are
rotation gates then I can simply like
decompose this rotation it is a product
of rotations of exponentially increasing
like binary binary angles and then
basically controlled on these registers
I can I can do this controlled rotation
so this is how I make my my circuit
constantly tunable and just one
application I wanted to show you is the
is the quantum of will include of things
which the idea is that we try to
compress quantum states which are in
this example five cubits to only two
qubits and I say that the compression
was successful if I can recover it with
another map which takes some 0 inputs on
the three new qubit takes the encoded
two qubits and tries to restore the
original state it's a similar to the
classical scheme and inspired by it and
the question the success probability of
this circuit is just with if I would
measure now the input state which are
how high probability do I actually
measure the output state so this is kind
of the verification circuit and our like
actually this which undoes which
flippity state and this is like the tune
to
inserted so now I have an algorithm
which works using phase records and I
have applications which produce me
probabilities so I need to somehow feed
the two together so that I can actually
I can actually use my algorithm so I
define is probably the Oracle which is
just on yeah I guess I sorry the
accident is sinkage so it should have a
controlled register X so sorry it has
the zeroes of course because these are
the until s that I need to use but here
I should have the x factor so basically
on quantum state X its successes and
probability P and and so this
probability can be turned into a face
which Grover algorithm or a does
so the idea probe algorithm that if I
can prepare a quantum state which has
supposed P then I can look at this
amplitude and in particular this angle
with the Grover operator I can do
rotations of of angle 2 theta and this
is almost what I want I want something
like actually I want the probability
which is sine squared theta but I have
now rotations of angle 2 theta its
commit it's actually promising the
problem is that the display and the
spectrum of rotation is indeed it has
these two theta phases but it also does
a minus 2 theta phase so I somehow need
to get rid of it I'm not yeah so I can I
can imagine this as a Hamiltonian which
has theta and minus theta and I can I
can implement it it's been to I this
time
dona but i want to hamiltonian radishes
like sine squared theta so how can i do
that and here i use the linear
combination of unitary strick and why
it's probably to dance to digest all
right now the idea is that basically i
want e to the IP which is sine squared
theta and i just plug in this
hamiltonian because the sine square is a
if regardless of the sine of theta it
will be only the same and I just
basically expand it in the the Taylor
series use the trick that sine sine is
just sum of two exponential like two
phases and I just arrange the terms at
the end I can end with a formula where I
have the groover operators to some
powers with some coefficients turns out
that these coefficients can be basically
truncated at some logarithmic to the
high power so the idea is that I can I
can actually implement this phase using
a logarithmic number of global
iterations and some linear combination
it very quick and well you might would
say that this is actually nonsense thing
because global phase doesn't matter but
the whole algorithm will be run
controlled on some register so this will
be in fact the control phase and the
control phase is exactly what I want
this is what I want to put into the
gradient equation item control faded
base which is the phase Oracle which I
was hoping for so inside this
probability is just it's not a highroad
in this slide it's not a concert
probably it's just one particular
probability but this whole thing makes
sense when the whole procedure is
controlled on some extra registers
and yeah just for those who are not
familiar with this in our communities
the idea is that if I have immunity
Aires and I have some linear operator
which actually also entered in our case
because it's a phase where I call that
you want to simulate so suppose a
tiredest in your operator l which is a
sum which I can express as the sum of
the signatories then using this quantum
state which I shiny to prepare which
includes the coefficients I can express
this linear operator as basically first
people and on unselect qubits dis Ansel
estate then do controls on these
unsettle registers
apply the corresponding unitary and then
uncomputable be a nun normalized
operator and this can later be amplified
so I don't have to go to the details but
the main idea is that this quantum
procedure we have a success branch which
will have this unnormalized operation
and an unsuccessful branch and then
later I can do some rejection sampling
or epic amplification to actually make
sure that I end up the success branch so
in our case ad actually is unitary which
means that or at least very close to
unitary like very small up to negligible
error therefore we actually know the
success probability and it's well-known
fact in a in a in a follow up literature
of of ant amplification that if you know
the success probability of some quantum
procedure then you can use a so-called
exact an amplification which will give
you the success branch with a with
certainty and so we can use this stick
compared like in in combination with the
ICU llama so that the previous that
composition to some of unit Ares can be
actually after amplification give me
exactly this operator which I needed and
yeah if someone would worry about like
chaining because in athlete
amplification sometimes a one needs to
like undo be the quantum state on which
we want to apply the the cemetery that's
a problem but there is a technique
called oblivious antique amplification
which actually overcomes this difficulty
you don't need to uncomputable state
that you on which you want to act with
the unitary this is a three Twitter
which was introduced in the Hamiltonian
simulation papers recently yeah and
basically that's the idea just I want to
walk through you to once more that what
was the main reason that we developed
here so first ingredient was improved
gradient calculation algorithm using
high degree interpolation formulas or
finite difference formulas which
improved Jordans work and then we showed
how to actually convert success
probability to face limitary which which
gives me a face back and I showed an
application to machine learning mainly
the quantum auto-encoders paradigm and
the new ingredient here is the quantum
speed-up for training optimization which
might be helpful in the future when we
actually have many parameters and one of
the basic obstacles in in machine
learning is that your models have large
number of fallen
and the Train it that's the bottleneck
usually so one can imagine that if we
have large quantum computers you can
actually train these models quantum
models more efficiently so it is a hope
that in future applications when we have
large scale quantum computers you can
actually speed up machine learning
training itself not only the models that
like Nathan talked about yesterday
you can actually speed up the training
procedure as well using phantom
techniques and yeah that was my talk
thank you for your attention
[Applause]
are there any questions
yeah so you worked pretty hard to get
that sine squared theta into the
exponential but since you're using this
for optimization it seems like you could
replace it by any function monotonic
function of theta so like maybe theta
square or something so good could you
use that to simplify the algorithm yeah
definitely you could you could replace
it by basically any monotonic function
which is like yeah
which doesn't care about the sine of the
arguments for which is as you call
symmetric around zero but the thing is
that it actually gives you exactly what
you want to maximize the probability
itself which is aesthetically appealing
and also if it's not a very complicated
calculation after all so it's C it turns
out that because sine is a function
which is just the sum of two
Exponential's this is actually a nice
and easy formula so other functions
other functions can be harder I didn't
check all possibilities but section has
natural choice in terms of formula
complexity as well okay let's take
another question maybe David you can
probably take it oh and just just one
more thing that so basically why we use
sine is because we basically want to
Fourier decomposition so a fully a
decomposition is what we can deal with
because originally the global operator
is also in sort of Fourier basis so it
gives me a face and I want to work in
Fourier basis that's why I want science
so thanks for thanks for a nice talk I'm
wondering if this improvement also
exists for qualities like the laplacian
of the function or by a gradient moment
what do you mean by that is a Pascal
function grad square is ah yeah okay
yeah interesting I didn't look at the
laplacian but
for the Hessian you can use similar
tricks although you get like
comparatively smaller speed ups so for
the Hessian you would expect the
complexity classically be squared and
these methods seem to give you d to the
1.5 so it's not like the original
complexity square root but more like
square root improvement which we've seen
so far but maybe there is some other
idea which rank yep yeah so the classic
high complexity would be d squared or
for higher order things maybe B cubed
and the quantum complexity seems not to
be square root of the D power so
basically have the power but the
original classical complexity divided by
square would be less nevertheless the
original exponent okay thanks
any final questions before we go to the
next talk okay if not let's thank our
nourish again for a great talk then
we'll have a change of topic for the
next two talks we're going to shift a
quantum error correction and David
pucllana is going to tell us some
surprising new facts about quantum error
correction that hopefully we haven't
heard before
all right thank you thanks for inviting
me is this mic working yes okay so yeah
I'm going to present some work that were
was obtained by people in my group so
Andrew Darwin who's currently now
postdoc in Japan Nicola they're folks
who's here or just about to move and
have done evil still a PhD in my group
yeah so well surprising that I suppose
that I mean it's surprising to me and
you know let you be the judge after this
talk so let me explain to you like what
is motivating this this kind of this
line of research so let's say we want to
execute a quantum bug algorithm which
records and logical gates and so if you
want to do simulation of a molecule like
this ferredoxin you need something like
10 to the 12 10 to the 15 gates I don't
know if these numbers are
up-to-date but that's kind of
ballparking and anyway you'll see that
everything is at best ballpark here each
gate so so yeah you need a lot of gates
so each gate needs to be pretty accurate
how accurate well you know maybe the
errors will add up so you have n gate
each would accurate to Delta so maybe
the errors will just add up see so the
final error will be n times Delta but
that assumes that the errors build up in
a coherent way maybe they add up
stochastically in which case it might be
more like square root of N Delta and you
know we don't really know the answer to
that question and this tells us that
Delta and I'll consistently be using
Delta for the error of the in the
logical gate okay so the the logical
gate needs to be accurate to you know
either 1 over square root of N or 1 of n
so given these numbers you get that
gives us a pretty rough ballpark 10 10
minus 6 10 to the minus 15 right that's
what you need we need to be shooting for
and in this stuff I think it's fair to
say 10 to the minus 10 okay that's what
I'll be using as an example so we want
we want gates that are accurate to ten
digits let's say well we know that's the
fault-tolerant threshold theorem that if
the physical noise rate epsilon is below
the fault-tolerant threshold then we can
we can build faulty we can use fault
tolerant error correction to build
logical gates with an accuracy Delta and
the overhead will cost us you know
Pauline on Polly logarithmic in 1 over
Delta so epsilon is the accuracy of the
physical game and Delta is the accuracy
of the logical gate okay so here what I
want is to get a more kind of precise
answer to this question given a physical
physical noise rate Epsilon how much
error correction what's the overhead
that I need to achieve a logical noise
rate Delta that's kind of the question
that will be motivating this line of
research ok so I will present to you a
result that we obtained towards
answering that question but before I
present the result let me just present
the tool that I've used to obtain these
results ok
so the the summer is is that if you want
to simulate a fault-tolerant quantum
computer with realistic noise model well
that's a hard problem and in fact it's
just as hard as simulating a generic
interacting many-body system okay so our
contribution has been to use tools
numerical tools that were developed in
the context of quantum many-body physics
condensed matter physics in particular
to study these fault tolerant questions
okay so what tools well we've been using
tensor network methods so you may have
heard about things like density matrix
renormalization group the MRG our pets
are the mara so there are there's tons
of acronyms and we've used each of these
tools in different context of quantum
error correction okay so I won't I will
I don't have time to explain what these
tools are but I just want to say you
know they're out there and we can use
them for that type of research okay so
to understand how these tools can help
studying question and fault current we
need to understand what goes into a
fault tolerant simulation well here are
the the steps that you would have to
simulate so first you need to prepare
some encoded state typically these are
stabilizer codes so the encoded state
can be represented efficiently on a
quantum computer so then you write your
state as a density matrix and you apply
a channel okay you apply some noise to
that state now let me just open a
parenthesis here in many many many
numerical studies that have been made it
was assumed that the noise was
stochastic that the noise was like well
either this poly matrix occurs or this
value matrix occur and this is a great
simplification in this case you do not
apply the noise model to the state
instead you sample an error and you
apply that error to the state I want to
emphasize that these are very different
things okay
so for instance if you sample the noise
at every stage you
the pure state it's a random pure state
but you know what pure state you have
but if the noise is generate like let's
say amplitude amplification you can't
sample amplitude amplification you just
you take a pure state and it gives you a
mixtape
there's no sampling involved okay
so generically you need to just apply
the map the sampling occurs at the next
step so once you have annoys you state
the next step in error correction would
be to measure the syndrome and this is
something you have to simulate on the
computer so you need to compute the
probability of the various syndrome
outcome and this is just given by borns
rule and and so once you have the
syndrome the next step is to decode so
decoding is the process where you are
given a syndrome that gives you partial
information about how the system was
that was affected by errors and based on
this you try to figure out what's the
optimal recovery to bring the state back
to its original value then once you've
figured out what to do you apply that
you apply that correction and then you
get a post post error correction state
row prime and you evaluate what's the
difference between row prime and row and
that gives you you know what was the
logical error and in fact you can fully
characterize you could repeat this
several time or in fact we do something
slightly more clever what we do is we
start this encoded state is initially
entangled at an external reference so by
running this just once we know exactly
what was this channel that has been
applied to the logical qubit okay so
this just gives you complete access to
what logical transformation has been
applied to the logically encoded qubit
okay so if you are able well oh before I
move on I want to emphasize that there
are lots of steps in this procedure that
are computationally intensive so okay we
said this is the stabiliser state that's
not a problem I can I can do this all
right if I apply a noise model to a
stabiliser state I get a non stabiliser
state that requires a huge amount of RAM
and even if it's just non Paulino
without even mentioning correlated noise
model
that would just make everything blow up
okay so this is just memory intensive
now computing these probabilities
that's computationally intensive okay
these are exponentially large matrices
so just computing what's the probability
that if I measure this syndrome that I
get a plus on an outcome that's
computationally intensive decoding is
computationally intensive then I guess
well this is just multiplying by a poly
matrix but again you know these are
exponentially large matrices it's pretty
much every bullet point on this list is
computationally intensive now I want to
emphasize that this one here is crucial
because all the other bullet points are
about this simulation decoding is
something you'd have to do if you had a
quantum computer right you need to
decode the information so this is the
step that we that has to be efficient
the other steps don't necessarily need
to be efficient it helps if they are
because it you know it helps you do
these simulation but they don't need to
be so and I'll get back to this a bit
later okay so suppose that you are able
to do all these things what can you do
well someone comes up and says here's my
noise model it's Epsilon
well I can use the the procedure and
output a certain syndrome and say here
was here's the problem T that you would
have obtained that syndrome and given
the syndrome here is the logical channel
affecting your logical qubit and it's
typically it will depend on the syndrome
that you obtain and then you can repeat
this many time and average start
averaging stuff over the syndrome and
say this is my average logical channel
or I could say here's my average logical
error or here's the error of my logical
average these two things are not the
same and you know you can compute any
statistical figure of Merit that you
want okay so this was generic up to here
let me show you how this can be done for
the surface code so the surface code
that the the code states are peps so
peps is an acronym it's a projected
entangled pair states these are two
dimensional tensor network so I'm saying
you can write there's an efficient
representation
patient of the state vector that does
not require an exponential number of
coefficient and it's just represented by
a two-dimensional lattice of tensors if
you write down a identity matrix that
does not change this fact it remains a a
to D tensor network now I would like to
apply some noise model to that state and
I would like the result to also be a to
the tensor network so what type of noise
model allow me to do this well any noise
model that's a 2 D tensor network okay
if I apply a 2 D tensor Network noise
and I call this a pep so for so SOS for
super operator but that's more like a
joke but no one gets it so it's a but
the point is that if I have a noise
model that the two D tensor network and
I applied to the tensor network I just
get a 2 D tensor network this is very
very general okay I can do non
polynomial correlated noise model and so
on provided that the correlation or kind
of decay exponentially I can simulate
these things are at least it gives me a
2 D tensor network computing the
probability of a syndrome that that's a
two dimensional tensor network
contraction the post measurements take
I've just multiplied by a local operator
doesn't change the tensor Network
structure a poly correction is a tensor
product so this does not change at all
the tensor network structure and
computing the logical probability to do
like quantum state tomography again is
also just about contracting it to the
tensor network so all the
computationally intensive steps here
boil down to one operation contracting a
two dimensional tensor network now this
is hard
unfortunately there exist efficient
approximate contraction schemes okay
but in this work we have not used them
instead we did everything by brute force
so it is not efficient it's exponential
but it's exponential in the width of the
surface code not in the area and
therefore we were able to simulate
surface code with hundreds of qubits
which would not be possible without
using these tensor Network techniques
okay so to today so we I think the
biggest lattice we did is maybe
it was rectangular so maybe 10 by 15 or
something like this but there's no way
you could do this by brute force but
using tensor networks this was not a
problem so there are there are no
numerical errors in these simulations
okay the other type of code so this was
surface code we've also studied
concatenated code now concatenated code
this is what a concatenated code looks
like and just by looking at it you can
see oh yeah the tensor network behind
this is a tree and you know trees can be
contracted efficiently and indeed that's
the case now I mean you can think about
it more intuitively but what kind of
noise model can I put down here and and
such that the resulting tensor network
can be efficiently contracted well of
course if it's uncorrelated noise so I
just have you know independent noise on
each of these wires but it could be a
tree like noise right if the noise also
has a tree structure well then the whole
thing will be a tree it could be an NPS
so if I just put a string down here
turns out I can contract this it could
be a Mara there's a lot of interesting
noise model that I can study and still
have an efficient simulation of
concatenated code so these were the
tools I know this kind of high-level but
it just gives you an idea of why we were
able to carry these simulations so now I
want to present a few results that were
some of them were surprising to me hence
the title that were obtained with with
these tools okay so the first type of
result tells us something about metrics
so remember this was the question
motivating this entire line of research
well I have a physical noise rep salon
how much our correction do I need to
achieve a logical noise rate Delta well
how what what is Epsilon how do i
quantify the physical error rate well
some people like infidelity because it
has a nice statistical interpretation
and also you can measure it by
experimentally it's something that you
can probe by randomized benchmarking so
that's that's a nice way of
characterizing how noisy the physical
devices if you're a theorist you prefer
the diamond norm before because a
diamond norm come
as well so that's what's used in
theorems if you're lazy like me you
prefer the you know the helper Schmidt
norm because it's just like you take a
matrix you square it and you take the
trace nothing could be simpler but and
there's a lot a lot of other metrics now
and if you're not like a mathematical
physicist you might think you know get
on get on to the next slide I don't care
about norms but it turns out that it's
important because if you change norm the
noise could go from epsilon to square
root of epsilon so when we say the
threshold is about one percent is that
ten to the minus two or ten to the minus
four okay it makes a difference it's
important it's important to know what
what metric is the right one okay now
there's been a lot of work people were
aware of this and there's been a lot of
work trying to clarify the relation
between these norms in the last couple
of years so people well a lot of people
were focusing on the diamond norm
because this is the one that appears in
theorems but it's hard to measure
experimentally other than doing full
quantum process tomography so on the
other hand infidelity is easy to measure
by randomized benchmarking so people
were thinking is are there easily
accessible quantities that I can
measuring that allows me to put bounds
on on the diamond norm and people have
done this but so as far as I'm concerned
a useful norm is one that allows you to
predict the behavior of a system when
it's used you know to do quantum
computations if your norm does not
correlate with that well it's not very
useful so here's how well these norms
correlate so these are results of
numerical simulation for the thin code
using two layers of concatenation so the
horizontal axis is the physical noise
rate what I've been calling epsilon as
measured by the diamond distance okay
it's just one choice here it's a logical
failure rate Delta and appear this blue
line is the depolarizing channel so the
reason they're like little statistical
errors because I need to sample many
any syndromes okay so there are
statistical fluctuation but nonetheless
it's fairly convincing that you know and
we get a fairly accurate result and this
red line here is for a channel in which
every qubit is just rotated by some
small angle and the diamond norm is some
function of that angle what are the
other dots these are random channels so
I just generate a random noise model I
measure its diamond distance and then I
run like a million simulation with that
noise model and and I accumulate
statistic and gives this gives me a data
point like how how much logical error
was there given that channel I just
repeat this I think I've done 10,000
channels here okay
so what do we see here well let's say
that epsilon is ten to the minus two so
I have a physical system with a noise
rate you know of 1% how well with it
will it do in a fault-tolerant scheme
well you know with this with scenes code
it could have a physical noise rate a
logical noise rate that's anywhere
between ten to the minus eight to ten to
the minus sixteen okay or if you want to
turn it on its head and say look I was
shooting for ten to the minus ten so I
need to have a larger physical error
that's anywhere between ten to the minus
two to ten hundred minus one okay so
these are very extremely loose bounds
that it can give you so again if you
come up with the noise morrow let's say
this has you know there's one percent
noise as measured by the diamond
difference how well is it going to
perform in your fault tolerance scheme
if I answer you I have to put error bars
that span 10 orders of magnitude okay
and if you do more layers of
concatenation things get worse here I
mean we spend 14 orders of magnitude so
with the conclusion here well that the
conclusion is that the question I asked
at the beginning of this talk makes no
sense okay it is not possible to even
very very crudely predict the logical
failure rate of a fault-tolerant scheme
even only the noise rate of the physical
channel as measured by any of the
standard metrics so I showed the
previous
for the diamond norm but I've tried
every norm that I know of and the
conclusions were the same so things move
around but the the spread remains
roughly the same for some reason entropy
with the best but just by a small factor
like not orders of magnitude better so
the diamond norm does not send out in
any way so I I think people should stop
focusing on that norm so the good news
is that if you remember in the previous
slide are either of them the
depolarizing channel with the worse that
we've seen so this is kind of good news
because most like 90 percent of the
simulation that have ever been done
we're using the depolarizing noise and
that we learn from the assimilation that
these were very pessimistic things are
probably better than we think the bad
news is that this statement is norm
dependent so if I change the norm these
curves can switch okay so so yeah I
don't know what the take-home message
here is here it's just a lot of
confusion okay so the next kind of
question that we address using these
tools our channel approximation so as I
was saying at the beginning a lot of
people assume a stochastic noise model
in these fall torrents simulation
because then you can use pender Monte
Carlo and use the stabilizer formalism
to have an efficient simulation so all
of this coding stuff uses Clifford
circuit if you assume that the noise
model is either poly or Clifford a
stochastic noise model then you can
simulate the whole thing efficiently you
can do millions of qubits okay but in
reality the noise is never a palette
channel so you need some so given like a
physical noise model you need to
approximate it by a poly channel somehow
and then do the simulation with that
approximation okay that's that's a
procedure that people have been using so
one way to do this is kind of just drop
the the non non poly components in your
noise model so let me show you how this
is done with an example so suppose that
your noise model is that every qubit is
rotated by some small angle about the z
axis
so this is the unitary matrix that
results from this so the density matrix
gets sandwiched between this unitary so
you get four terms here but you're going
to drop two of those and only keep the
direct terms you're going to drop the
cross terms and say look I can replace
this channel by a model where with
probability coasts Co square theta
nothing happens and with probability
sine square theta I have a Z error C so
now this is a poly normal and then this
is very easy to simulate it's called the
twirled poly approximation and again
it's kind of a similar thing right you
simplify the model and then you do the
simulation for this simplified model
another poly approximation that has been
introduced is called this honest poly
approximation so let me show you what
the idea is so you try to find a palette
channel so this is your real noise model
you try to find a palette channel that
is as close as possible subjected a
constraint that it's further away from
the identity so it's as close as you can
be without being better okay so this is
called an honest approximation and now
you do your numerical simulations with
this valley approximation in principle
you can generalize this so on kanna's
generalize this to Clifford noise but
you couldn't choose correlations and so
I think that's a very good idea and it's
a very rich so here are results that we
obtained this is for the surface code
these are treshold estimate and on as I
was saying these are you can see fairly
big lattices okay so the biggest one was
this nine by 17 so for some noise model
it turns out to it's better to have an
asymmetric lattice and this was the case
for amplitude damping so alright
depolarizing channel is a poly channel
so of course the threshold remains the
same whether whether you use a poly
approximation or not it's about 18%
amplitude damping the exact threshold
that we found using this scheme is about
39 percent and that's extremely high the
poly twirl gave the same result the
honest tally was much much more
pessimistic about 6% and the z-rotation
is just weird the exact simulation don't
show a threshold it's it's just weird so
I don't know what to think about this
but let's look at sub-threshold behavior
this is a bit more informative so this
is for amplitude damping the the full
line is the exact result so this is as
we increase the lattice size and for a
damping rate of 9% how with the logical
error rate so you can see it drops
exponentially with the lattice size as
expected if you replace the the
amplitude damping channel by its twirled
approximation you get about the same
results okay so this is very good but
the honest Polly approximation is much
more pessimistic as it should right
dishonest poly approximation doesn't say
it's a good approximation it's just
honest so it gives you it gives you
upper bound so might draw the conclusion
that a you know these plural
approximations are pretty good but then
you go to a different noise model the
systemic rotation Channel and now here's
the exact result here's the twirled
approximation and here's the honest
value approximation so you see again
like I don't know like six or seven
orders of magnitude difference between
these results okay so with the
conclusion here it's that it is not
possible to even crudely
predict the logical failure rate of a
fault-tolerant scheme from non poly
approximation it seems like you need to
simulate the real noise model if you
want to know how it will behave so the
total approximation gets good threshold
estimates in that like handful of
examples that we've studied I would not
you know take this for granted there
might be exceptions to this yeah so I
mean we saw that I mean the
approximations can go either way so none
of them are reliable okay so I think
this this motivates the development of
tools these many-body tools to simulate
the exact noise model alright the last
little bit I want to talk about is
decoding so as I said early on like
there's a lot of this come
Alexa T that goes into simulating fault
tolerance but decoding is something you
need to do regardless of whether you're
simulating or you actually have a
quantum computer so this thing we should
work hard to make it efficient if we can
and even for poly noise decoding is in
general a hard problem but we have
instances of code with efficient
decoding algorithm sometimes these
decoding algorithms are suboptimal um so
generically for non poly no you're just
making the problem even more complex so
finding a decoder that works for non
poly know is it's very challenging and
and of course you can add correlations
to this so of course but you can use a
heuristic decoder so you can say alright
even though the noise is non poly when I
run my decoder I will just assume that I
have a polynomial and just keep my
fingers crossed and hope for the best
that's something you can do it's
suboptimal but at least you get
something efficient and same comment
applies to correlated noise model you
could just like further purpose of
decoding ignore these correlations and
get something suboptimal but our
simulation method by if you represent
things by tensor network combine to
efficient but approximate contraction
scheme for a tensor network provide an
efficient decoder that applies to a very
wide range of non poly and correlated
noise model ok so you can have so you
get a decoder which I mean the tensor
network is an exact decoder and then use
an approximate contraction scheme for
that decoder so here's how well it
performs so this is for amplitude
damping this green line is if you use
matching to decode an amplitude damping
channel so matching is sort of like
let's just ignore let's just pretend
it's a poly channel like a bit flip
channel and let's be code using the
standard decoder for that and the let's
see the red line down here is
the exact tensor network contraction so
this one scales exponentially and the
blue line is the efficient tensor
Network contraction algorithm okay so
essentially by using these efficient
contraction scheme as far as decoding is
concerned we see no difference and we
have now many other examples like this
in particular we have example that go to
much lower noise rate and this
approximate decoding is always extremely
close to the exact decoder this is
another example where we studied
correlated noise model so this is the
surface code this so that well the way
we said this up the correlations are
kind of mediated by some Ising model and
this J here just represents the coupling
in the Ising model so it's a measure of
how correlated the errors are and P is
just like the the number of errors that
the frequency of errors and the this is
a log scale so down here you have very
few errors in here very higher but I'm
just showing this to show that you know
this decoder can handle non valley and
or correlated errors and not a problem
okay
so just here are my general conclusions
so of the question motivating this line
of research was given a physical noise
rate Epsilon how much error correction
do I need to achieve a logical noise
rate Delta I think that first conclusion
is that this question that they make any
sense there's not enough data in the
question to provide an answer but what
we've done we've used methods from
quantum many-body physics to address
this question for the surface code and
concatenated code here are a few
highlights of what we found for a fixed
physical and noise reps alone as
measured by any of standard metric the
logical failure rate can fluctuate by
several orders of magnitude the diamond
norm is no better than any other norm in
that regard the logical failure rate of
poly approximations can differ by
several orders of magnitude from the
true failure rate for a given diamond
norm physical error and kill incoherent
noise is is worse and that's what we
found I mean we haven't gone exhausted
exhaustively through all the noise model
but based on our simulation that's what
we found
and for a few examples of floral
approximation seems to give a reasonable
threshold estimate okay but not
necessarily of sub-threshold behavior
which is what we really care about and
we've also developed an efficient
decoder for non poly and correlated
noise on the surface code now I think
that these tools can become useful for
experimentalist because like let's say
let's say an experimentalist comes up to
me and says you know here's here's the
noise model that I that I think
describes my qubit in the lab how well
will it what it behaves in
fault-tolerant so this is something I
can simulate and then maybe they think
oh you know I have a pretty small t2 so
I'll put a grad student on you know
improving that t2 but I can use the
simulation tool and say you know what if
you improve that t2 it's not going to
help you what's really killing you is
this off diagonal matrix element in your
process matrix that's what you should be
spending your grad student and trying to
improve right so I can use these tools
sort of give guidelines to to
experimentalist and more generally so
what we see is that just learning about
the infidelity of a channel or the
diamond distance is not enough data to
understand how the channel will behave
in a fault-tolerant scheme and this begs
the question what do we need to know
about the noise model what are the
critical parameters of a noise model
which determine how well it will behave
in a fault tolerance scheme so you know
we have this database now with tens of
thousands of channels and the
corresponding behavior in a fault
torrent scheme and we've been trying to
use machine learning techniques to try
to extract features of the noise model
that correlate with the logical failure
rate but I'm sad to report that we
haven't succeeded in doing this but I
think it remains kind of a crucial
question to determine what are these
what are the critical parameters that we
need to extract from from experiment to
understand fault I'm alright with that I
thank you for your attention
great thank you
other questions for you um anyway I so I
think it is really amazing that this
diamond norm seems to be really useless
for determining whether or not your
error correcting code works and there's
also this recent results about classical
error correction on this issac model
where they do this for you for me on
contraction thing and so one thing I've
been thinking about a little bit is the
diamond norm the reason why people like
it it's like given given the ability to
distinct
given basically ability to take anything
to distinguish the channel this is how
well I can distinguish things but these
policies stabilizer codes don't ask
those questions right they just ask well
is it a poly fixable thing or not
probably fixable things okay and do you
think there's any way to make a
reasonable norm from that or is it also
fall into this list of bedrooms well I
think I've reached the conclusion that
this is not a one-parameter question
right it's clearly just a high
dimensional problem but it's about how
many how many dimensions are there and I
don't think these necessarily will have
anything to do with norms and I have a
few eristic argument that I could try to
run by you see if you buy that so when
designing your code for the future
should we look at the tensor
decomposition techniques rather
stabilizers and base our decoding and
our structures on that on making that
work well well this is definitely
something that I think is is important
in it just as a side comment I've
designed new classical error correction
based on tensor network so yes heck yes
right so so I have one more question so
when you do Monte Carlo simulations a
big problem usually is to go to low
error rates so it is still a problem for
your message or is actually does it
solve this problem now okay now you're
you're getting on to something yeah yeah
so you may have noticed that I report
very very low failure rate in these
plots like 10 to the minus 20 or
something but I haven't ran 10 to the 20
simulations so how can I report these
number well I mean uh well basically a
massive description I would guess that
the answer he gives us over council know
well it doesn't it doesn't but indeed
like when you do a poly noise model and
you sample from it you either get the
right correction or the wrong correction
if you have a more generic noise model
there's no right or wrong correction
there I mean for every correction
there's some residual noise and if you
do even one run and you see that the
residual noise is 10 to the minus 20 you
can report 10 to the minus 20 right
without sampling 10 to the 20 times and
this is why we example each of these
data point was about a million sample so
this is really the typical failure rate
it's not the average because what we've
noticed is that there are serious
outliers so it could it could it could
be that there's a syndrome that occurs
only once every billion sample that
leads to an order 1 failure so this 10
to the minus 20 should really read 10 to
the minus 9 and this remains a problem
and I think it's really important to
notice that the typical fit the typical
error is not the average error but I
mean but don't you like care in practice
about it shows a typical behavior well I
think that when you notice you can do
something about it ok take a budget ok
thank you
thanks to deed I've actually got a got a
question have you looked into the
continuity the logical error rates when
you perturb one of the channels about
one of those points no but this isn't
that we were okay one thing we thought
about doing is for a given channel
computing the gradient around that point
so that seems like a pretty natural
thing to do that could you know along
the lines of what I was saying an
experimentalist comes up with a channel
try to figure out what's what's what's
the bottleneck in its noise model and
what should it be working on so I think
that goes along this line and I think
yeah there's a lot to be done great and
while we take these next two questions
maybe can you consider yeah so my
question goes into a similar direction
as Mason's have you looked at how
sensitive your decoder is to changes in
the noise model so if you assume of
wrong noise models if your details are
still performing decently or is it
completely off that's a good question
I haven't checked this I think I don't
expect it to change much and but like
but what I I consider big changes to the
noise model for instance like if it's
correlated and you assume it's not then
you make you know then you that leads to
substantial error if you don't have
exactly the right correlation model
which is what you're asking I haven't
tested it I don't I don't expect it to
be pretty bad but in some sense it is a
way of accessing the critical parameters
right if you get this this thing off a
little bit and things go dramatically
wrong that thing was critical yeah so my
my very primitive understanding of
concatenation is that every layer of
concatenation sort of squares the
logical error rate right so with your
two levels of concatenation on the steam
code do you see this born out is there
an order epsilon forth yeah I mean yes
so that it's a polynomial with the
lowest degree is quadratic and it's not
something we have tested well I mean
this something we've looked at a long
time before and generally yet it's
so this is a very good rule of thumb
about concatenation yes yes that there
is of course the prefactor which is
important and this is related to weight
and numerator and this is something that
we can access also in America it's
roughly the square of the number of
publications I guess all right it's
roughly the square of the number of full
plication right that right yeah yeah it
can be pretty bad too it can be fairly
large great let's think David again for
a wonderful talk
[Applause]